foreign
's in Louisville Kentucky hey Brandon
what's up
hey thanks for taking my call today sure
how can we help
so I have a question about what I should
where I should be focusing my money so I
went through majority of your steps I am
debt free
um with everything besides my house I do
the 15 into my retirement to my 401k I
have a relatively new son that's six
months old so I started the 529 and
started investing in that
thank you but my question is so I I
bought a house
um a couple years ago two three years
ago bought a pretty good time my
mortgage that I have left on it is about
250 000.
um it's worth around 300 to 315 000
um but I've put about fifty thousand
dollars in individual stocks and then I
have an additional a hundred and three
thousand roughly in just savings on the
side and my question is should I be
taking that money out of the individual
stocks and trying to beat that mortgage
down as much as possible or how should I
be investing this money what should I be
focusing on a Direction with this money
you seem you seem like you're awfully
familiar with what we do uh-huh
until that last part
relatively new to listen to you guys
it's probably been a few months uh not
I've been listening to you guys but but
you know the baby steps but yeah like I
said I love the I love the method you
guys you try to make it as simple as
possible but I feel like I'm at the
point where like I'm still relatively
young but I'm like I want to get ahead
as fast as possible you do look I'm not
gonna stay in this home forever but I'm
probably gonna move out of it in a
couple years so I'm like does it make
sense no beat down my mortgage here or
let me help you let me help you what
you're what you've been doing which is
the baby steps has been working for you
so let's keep on doing that so the way
we would teach it is you're already
investing in the 529 that's great you've
got all this extra money the 50k in
single stocks 103k is that above and
beyond your three to six months I'm
assuming
yeah that is everything uh yeah in a
savings portion so what we would do next
is put you know we're paying off the
mortgage so you've got this extra money
if if it were me I would can't I would
cash out the 50k and single stocks there
is going to be some tax implication
there so you've got to be prepared for
that but I would do that because you've
got 250 left on this mortgage you could
pay off 150
by the end of the month what's your
household income
um so I make around 250 000. and you're
how old
uh 26. okay way to go you're doing
really good Brandon she's so good what
we have discovered in studying
millionaires
not not someone's theory on Tic Tac but
real millionaires okay what we've
discovered in studying 10 000 of them is
the shortest distance between where you
are and the first one to five million
dollars is two things
loading your 401ks at 15 of your income
going in like you're doing and becoming
100 debt free using what used to be
payments then to build wealth with by
steadily investing
okay the number of millionaires that we
interviewed and we interviewed 10 000 of
them that said I ran up a bunch of
profit in single stocks and and used
that to pay off my house and that caused
me to be rich was almost nothing almost
none of them there was a few but there's
percentage-wise it would have been well
less than five percent of them 95
percent of them followed the plan of not
just our plan but just the idea the
common sense idea of my most powerful
wealth building tool is this wonderful
income you have because you're obviously
bright you're 26 years old you make 250
000 dumb people don't do that so we know
you're bright okay and so uh that that
you know that that is your secret sauce
not the stocks not leveraging your house
you are the secret sauce in the equation
so if I'm you uh I put a hundred and
fifty thousand minus an emergency fund
if you set aside 20 for your emergency
fund so 100 130 000 on your two hundred
fifty thousand dollar loan and you have
a two hundred fifty thousand dollar
income with no other payment so I think
I understood that that's right and that
means I'm gonna knock off you're going
to be debt free when you're 28 house and
everything and then you've got 250
000 freaking dollars to invest steadily
You're Gonna Be A Millionaire when
you're 35 if you do what we tell you to
do
I am paying uh PMI on my mom I'm mad at
you you're brilliant you've done a great
job
fine tuning your excellent plan you
pulled up here in an Indy car all we're
doing is tuning it up
okay well I just you know how it is you
like to look at the bank you like to see
the the savings I'm really good about
stockpiling money let me tell you what
let me tell you I don't know how it is
what I know how it is is when you pay
off your house and you walk through the
backyard without any shoes on the grass
feels different
it probably does it does I promise you
so here's the thing if I'm wrong and to
in a year and a half from now you're 100
debt free and you hate it you can go get
you a mortgage
that's a great way to look at it all
right hey man pay off your house as fast
as you possibly can that's your next
step and and don't get too caught up in
the stocks
pretty much a gamble I don't buy single
stocks we recommend if you're going to
do single stocks just because you can't
stand it for whatever reason not to have
more than 10 of your net worth in single
stocks I buy mutual funds that's all I
do and and real estate that I pay cash
that's all I do I built 100 of my wealth
doing that that's all I've done it's
very simple and you know he made a good
point the thing you have to watch
against and Brandon he didn't get there
but he walked up on the edge of it I
heard him
he's not really there because he's very
smart yeah he is obviously a smart young
man okay when I was his age
I would have been more than smart I
would have been arrogant okay yes that
would have been the category I would
have been in so here's what I find he
said you guys what you teach is so
simple and there's a lot of compliment
in that but there was also a but I know
better because I'm smarter than simple
yeah he wanted there to be more be
smarter than simple if you get smarter
than simple that's when you get your toe
cut off in the lawnmower
just don't get don't get smarter than
simple it's a bad idea because let me
just tell you some of the most profound
life-changing things you will learn in
this life are very easy to understand
and very hard to do let me give you one
yes yes love your neighbor
but he's a jerk yeah I know what to do
doing it oh my gosh simple design I mean
I got a lot of the guys on Tic Tac and
Twitter oh man
oh
I know what to do I just can't do it
it's simple it is simple but not easy
very simple some of the things that most
profound things are simple but not easy